uh this is always so exciting and we're
live hey guys welcome to the weekly poll
as usual I don't have my comic books
Andy but I have a bunch of Trades so
we're going to go teenage be nja
journals Miss Marvel low L is upside
down Wonder Woman waywards upside down
and rage of Ultron all right that's all
I got I got raage of I'm the comic story
and that is s from TV little house also
known as comic pop now that is f from it
super effective that is Rob from a
Comics explained thingy that is the goat
head known as Mr Sunday and that is Joel
from comic book cast for the record Mr
Mr Sunday is our actual guest Joel just
kind of showed up on our front door
so how I got my other job on the other
podcast I figure if I just start showing
up enough they'll be too polite to ask
me to
leave oh no I'll tell you get the hell
out Joel get the hell
out okay no don't go oh God that is the
loudest commercial ever on YouTube the
Van Halen one just kicked up
on what what van Hal Halen commercial
what are they what are they selling I
don't know as a Van Halen commercial
just jumped in Van Halen live on
tour God that would be
a oh yeah I like Van Halen Man not van
Hagar oh my God second I thought you
meant like van housing and I was like
okay everyone like the goat to stop
facing them do you need to turn the goat
around Mr Sunday turn the goat around
the goat the goat for your image your
image is a goat
[Laughter]
it's your go head all right guys today's
topics are three biggies today we're
going to be talking about convergence
because zero came out we got a whole
bunch of issues coming out tomorrow um
we're going to give our theories our
thoughts as to what's going on with that
we're also going to talk about the
Daredevil show uh what our favorite
stories for Daredevil are what our
channels are going to be doing for
Daredevil what's happening with
Daredevil I know Mr Sunday's got a whole
bunch of videos about Daredevil so he
can fill us in on all the Netflix
goodness that we don't know um and then
we're probably going to talk about why
me and F love Hugh Jackman and we're
going to miss him so
so
yeah let's do it that's going to be a
really one-sided conversation I mean
this is I don't know like I don't know
what to say to something like that hey I
I I like him too but I mean like the
X-Men series is never going to evolve or
change while he sticks around so I mean
yeah so let's start with you Jackman
since I just threw out there and the
awkward silence happen get the awkward
face from F wait what I mean I I I want
short sort of Stumpy really really hairy
Wolverine
sure for that who who do you get though
like who's like someone new just a No
Name there are lots of actors out there
that are really good that we haven't
heard of I mean Game of Thrones got a
bunch of no names in and they were
amazing so so I don't see why we just
Wolverine and also if this no became
Wolverine then we wouldn't say oh that's
Hugh Jackman as Wolverine or whatever
we'd say that is Wolverine yeah y like
they would become like I've been saying
that's what they should be doing for
these superheroes anyway because they're
icons and we shouldn't be saying oh
that's such and such a list celebrity as
true character we could ruin their lives
and pigeonhole them into that one rle
for costume Adam West TR Believe In This
Modern Day movie age it's the costumes
that sell the movies not the actors who
are wearing the costume absolutely you
look at the judge Robert Danny junor
like nobody saw that you know but it if
it was Iron Man you know defense's Dad
who murdered somebody or whatever
that does he wear armor in this one no I
so it's like Iron Man 3 okay no then
well you know kind of go with to kind of
go with that whole thing um I I mean Rob
ber Jer Jr goes on doing all kinds of
Charities and everything because he's
still trying to clean up his image for
when he was a bad boy you know yeah and
you never hear about any of them the
only ones you ever hear about is Robert
Dani junor showed up and gave a Iron Man
looking for prosthetic arm to a little
boy it's like you are aware that he did
like five other things this month but
that's the one we're going to focus on
because it involves iron man do you
think do you think Robert Danny Jr would
have been hired if Disney owned Marvel
first because they have a strict like no
criminals policy I think the only one
that got through was Tim Allen who was
in jail for for cocaine distribution or
something and Tom man know I mean like
the fact is Robert D Jr got clean before
it wasn't like up he'd cleaned up before
Iron Man so I think they would have let
him go I think they would it sold
cocaine I mean like I mean Marvel kind
of are well not Marvel um Sonia kind of
are hiring uh not even only Fox that
kind of are hiring no names because of
this uh woman that plays Jubilee I kind
of looked at her and went who the hell
are you yeah and then moved on but then
I was like Hey Jubilee in a movie good
character
she's been in uh she was in two X-Men
movies played by two totally different
actors each
time completely disparaging ethnicities
and uh
ages sometimes she's on the outside of a
deleted scene ah there you
goet does she does she only show up on
July 3D and she's off of the movie by
July 5th that's what needs to happen
like like like Jubilee needs to have a
cameo and like she just needs to show up
where everybody's like hanging out and
like they're like man like we don't have
any fireworks and Jubilee's like hey I
can save the day and so she just like
shoots fireworks into the sky and like
that's her role and that's
[Laughter]
it every time we track jokes about the
firework Jubilee he's just like stop do
it f do it leave
Jubilee no until I'm drunk no no okay
okay like okay here's deal step a wipe
off of now and get drunk come back like
that's yeah how would to say that like
here here was the de okay so like like a
new X-Men Emma fr was like hey I'm just
going to like jump into people's bodies
and control their abilities and like
just push them to the Limit whatever she
took over like Jubilee's body and she
was like Hey guys like she has potential
to be really power she can like detonate
matter on a subatomic scale and no one
cared people were just like so everyone
just focused on her ability to change
Iceman and make him all cool oh that's
right that's great Iceman though okay
but at least you can admit dasler is
cool when the writer has the right
imagination to use her powers properly
dazzler turn 1970s to fight vampires
with dead with Deadpool yeah that I was
thinking that one too like sending it
back to the 1980s taking away the limit
on her power and making her the herald
of Galactus that was so basically she's
only good when it's just a off-the-wall
story they they made her president in
like an alternate future of Uncanny
X-Men it's like and now introducing
president
dazzler she like just to set up set up
to sh on her once again you're right
you're right you're toally okay okay
here's here's here's my question all
right so Mr Sunday
movies would like dazzler or Jubilee be
like reason enough for you to go like
okay would that draw you to go see an
exp movie would you be like oh my God
like jubile is going to be in the new
Xmen fil like oh my God like I'm say
look I'm the kind of person obviously
that would say that regardless but that
doesn't add or lessen anything that's
just a thing that's happening and I it's
fine whatever or if didn't happen that's
fine like whatever that's what I'm
saying like like no one cares about
Jubilee's character just like she was an
exp in anima of series cool that's
that's exactly why you hit the nail on
the head right there this is this is to
get all those 90s kids who have dispos
blink can hey remember Jubilee your like
point of view character from the X-Man
animated well she's in this now like
remember the cover for X-Men 92 for
Secret Wars she is dead Center
foreground bubble blown no question oh
yeah that's definitely designed to reach
out to the X-Men the Animated Series
kids I mean there that's your way of
knowing it's X-Men animated otherwise
you're just like oh cool Jim Le's X-Men
I'm in it's like no no no no no it's
Jubilee the cartoon I can't even deny
that that's probably the reason why I
like Jubilee so much because I don't
remember X-Men the unanimated series
like not being there yeah it was just
like it's just always been there as far
as I'm concerned if anyone says it
wasn't
it was a crazy time before the X-Men
animated series cuz all you had was the
rumors of this awesome pilot with Kitty
pride in the same exact role as God
Pride of the X-Men of the X-Men free on
YouTube it's everywhere he was a
disaster but no that animation was
knowbody like Wolverine in the X-Men I
think that was a great re remake this
one's for you
more wolver I like X-Men evolution I
will defend X-Men evolution tion was
pretty okay I didn't my problem was I
liked Wolverine versus or Hulk versus I
liked Hulk versus Wolverine Hulk versus
Thor that was cool and that version of
Wolverine was really awesome and then
they tried to say that it happened that
it's the same thing from wolver the
X-Men he still can't stab anything he's
a man with six knives coming out of his
hands and he can't kill anybody with
them you've neuter Wolverine like cuz in
the whole X-Men animated series it's
such a great cartoon but Wolverine's
like now it's time for me use my Adam
anium claw to cut that guy hold hold
back
Wolverine we need a door cut is he a
robot no he is a robot you can yeah yeah
you can is he a robot yet is he a robot
I'll kill the Sentinel I'll stab him as
many times I didn't stab a person in
this entire series he he did it in Hulk
versus Wolverine though because he cut
Dead's arm in three
chunks half episode like putting it back
together yeah okay okay but like I mean
sit down and imagine for a second all
right it's like 1996
and you're like 11 years old not even
it's like 94 okay what 93 94 something
like that but you're like 11 years old
or something I think I think maybe I was
like nine or 10 and like I'm sitting
down the internet will turn on you
what it's
true I mean I'm sitting down and like
I'm I'm watching I'm watching the show
and all of a sudden Wolverine just like
busts out his claw and just like slashes
a guy's throat open and blood goes
everywhere blood like sprays against the
wall I mean like how extrem would that
be I'll actually give you let me give
you a perfect example of that moment
Batman the Animated Series Bane finally
gets on the show they CH to the new
advent of Batman and Robin they
introduce Bane Nightfall is still going
on yeah I know right like azreel is
still Batman at this point and you're
seeing Bane on the cartoon you're like
oh they're gonna change it like they're
gonna crack his back on the cartoon
show he defeats Bane easily and it's
amazing it's way better than Nightfall
in that cartoon spoilers by the way for
20-year-old cartoon uh man what oh Mr
Sunday there goes our Sunday it was my
Netflix queue man come on yeah I know
it's not on Netflix it'd be awesome if
it was however every episode is on
Amazon I think I just yes it is yes it
oh is it on Amazon Prime yeah oh my God
man I'm watching so uh I go to the comic
book store the next day and I go and
he's and my Comic Book Guy is like so
did you see Batman I'm like oh my God
Bane I'm like but wouldn't it have been
cool if they had actually done the
Nightfall story line and he goes so let
me just show you an idea of bat man's
back being broken and 8-year-old boys
and girls just watching the show and
just the crack Across America and
everyone just being like what no yeah I
guess that's doesn't that's not GNA work
they can't even they can't even break
glass on the show F true there were a
whole bunch of like Studio notes one of
them was you can't strangle anybody you
can't break glass nobody can go through
a GL like through a glass window it was
all these things that were like don't
replicate like some kid grabs brother
throw and yet that episode question they
kill a woman in that episode is the
thing they do it very subtly but if
you'll remember rert Thorne has a
henchwoman oh she's in there no at the
end of it all right you mean like rert
Thorne has her murdered after the end of
the show you never see her again after
that episode he totally murdered her
because she she she was trying to pull a
power play she was trying to get into a
relationship with Bane and overthrow
rert Thorne and he
yeah remember that didn't she have like
black hair or something she have black
hair she was cool she was
b um yeah Jackman is
Wolverine by the way throw out my my my
pick I think I would be totally okay
with Carl Carl Urban playing wol yeah
okay definitely but is he too old like
cuz he's what I was worried about him
kind of like being kind of like being
like 21 Jump Street with the cast of
Star Trek where he's like yeah right
everybody we're we're cool
you're all like 20 and I'm like 40 but
no it's fine I don't know I think that'd
be I think he could pull it off I think
as long as he grows a big beard and he's
just like he's grumpy I think no I think
noone's G him a pass all right so I've
pulled up a list of 10 guys who could be
Wolverine oh shoot let's hear it I let's
get everyone's opinion but Rob you had
something you've been trying to say I no
no no um no as far as the whole as far
as the whole Carl Urban thing like I was
I was in the same boat as s for a while
where I was like uh I don't know and
then and then I saw red and then I saw
him going totally like I saw him in like
the whole I mean it was a scripted fight
you know obviously between him and bris
but he's still like agile and athletic
enough he could hold his own in terms of
like I like that show what was that show
he was in that got cancelled oh the one
with the robots yeah I didn't mind that
that was okay yeah I was like that's all
right Fox I got caned
immediately fo all right so here we go
so this list is provided by
hollywood.com because I don't want to
make my own so thanks
Hollywood so there say number 10 Russell
Crow I'm gonna have to Google these
people aren't I you don't know who
Russell Crow is Russell Crow is like one
of the greatest did did you never did
you never see the Cinderella Man
Gladiator one of the Gladiator
like
play and you guys need to go through
this with me at the same time because
they've what they've done is they added
Wolverine hair in claws to every one of
these actors oh so the second one is
Thomas Jane oh I oh no cuz he's he's
going to do the Punisher he's never
G I thought he said he was gonna be the
Punisher no he he was wasn't he he's he
he hates well he's he quit after uh
after the first yeah he quit after war
zone was gonna be such garbage Oh I
thought he said that like like I thought
he said that he would come back and he
would play The Punisher if Marvel
brought him into the Marvel Cinematic un
I would love that he's the defens he's
already B stag he's already one of the
Warriors 3 remember but then again I
guess he could go back ston oh [__]
punish for not St
I oops I [__]
up I want someone I want someone that's
dumpier than this guy right that's fair
so far all these options are are tall
all right vgo mortis I can't I
cannot no way I like him a lot but he
would be the mumbl Wolverine ever
he would just
walks he would just start randomly
singing and people would be just
[Music]
be he's to pretty like my Wolverine's
got to be a little rough is you know
he's got to be a guy who's lived some
years seen some stuff he has n
flashbacks and he wasn't even in Nom
AB even I guess even though he's the
Hulk at one point in this career now
he's potentially Wolverine no dear God
no Norton
no act that nearly were Wolverine or
that will or could be Wolverine this he
could be like these are no under no
circumstances could Edward Norton play
Wolverine Wolverine would come to life
in the comics and kill Edward Norton for
playing
Wolverine did think Edward n make a
really good Bruce ban I thought I'd like
that I love every time I see the movie
every time I watch Avengers I'm like
could have been Edward Norton could have
been he didn't want to play ball he
demanded Final Cut on all of his movies
because he's Edward freaking Norton yeah
he always does that he's notorious for a
diva
yeah um Glenn Danzig
danzing Dan only five five4 so he looks
Stumpy enough but he looks slightly too
old and he's not an actor so that's it
old wizard pick he said he he was quoted
a few years ago was saying how would you
have played Wolverine because it was
rumed in the 90s and he said I would
have played it less gay like he said
that wow no he doesn't get
Wolverine S no I like Gary s where where
I don't understand like what list my dad
that's exactly it like like it was
people who sat down and said hey guys
let's pick people who have like almost
won Oscars in like the last this like
let's make a list of who's playing
Wolverine who is that again you know was
just a list of actors and they just said
they could be Wolverine Wolverine you
think they just said who can we easily
shop Wolverine hair on
to I I will say this like Wolverine is
pretty fantastic Aaron earts yeah I like
eart a lot but I don't see him as
Wolverine no
yeah everyone like you know what I
almost feel like I feel like they just
picked a whole bunch of actors who wear
leather
jackets
I I will give I will give Aaron eart
this though like he can play like a
gritty to the ground kind of guy if you
saw battle Los Angeles he was like a
down to the ground kind of guy like he
was really Co that movie's terribleness
he was Thank You for Smoking is a great
one
tooing oh I love that one yeah Doug Ray
Scott Doug Ray Scott I don't know how he
was wolver he was in orig cast water
yeah he was he had to drop out and then
he ended up doing he dropped out
impossible too and then he which is
terrible it's the worst worst and then
he did went on Desperate Housewives so
oh what you do what's going on Rob like
it's like the world's ending outside my
house that bad huh it's thundering and
lightning so bad you're before you die
can I get access to your YouTube channel
no my YouTube happens every time Rob's
almost Gonna Die Why have all their
number 10 pick or the one one before the
their number two is not
Bob oh my God okay this is has to be
like dead is he dead yeah he's been dead
for two
years HK Bob HK we can just like but we
can just like get his corpse and attach
it to Strings like a marionette
we can we just agree that can we just
agree that the next time we're going to
do this I don't pick the first one on
the list when I Google who could
play I've enjoyed this a lot f f whole
thing is met like I mean like hoskin's
like hey what are you
doing get out of
here I'm
aive be careful guys we have real knives
on his hands so don't go near that we
really can't control what's going on
with those anymore just around oh my God
this website moves so slow
too okay okay so that's I think that's
like that's the ultimate problem there's
one more there's one more this is the
ultimate one they are recommending their
number one pick John Claude vanam yes
yes I will dude let me tell you
something if it has John Claude vanam
I'll go see it and that's just the way
the world looks no I am 100% serious
that is the world according to Rob if it
has jeanclaude vanam I will sit in a
theater and watch it as terrible as it
may be I watch you need to talk to our
mean more because he's a huge fan like
he's just like every day he's like Joel
let me talk to you about blood sport and
all these other movies oh yes Blood
Sport man so what you're saying is if
Hollywood made a movie about your life
you would have jeanclaude vanam play you
oh yes I would have have I'd have Morgan
Freeman narrated and John Claude Van
would like play me okay I'm just GNA say
I'm just picturing like one of those
cartoon series you're not exactly a buff
guy Rob so I'm picturing something like
Homer Simpson or like you know like
Family Guy and then John is like I
am okay no way freaking Family Guy no
way but I will say blood Sport's like
the greatest movie of all time okay
never say blood sport I got to watch
sorry it's not we didn't You' never seen
Blood Sport oh my god dude I'm saying
time cop does that care for anything oh
no time cop's not okay James check this
out so Blood Sport blood Sport's like
the best movie ever I know I know
exactly what it is I'm just a movie guy
like Mr Sunday movies does more I was
like surely you know what BL that's why
I was surprised like surely you know
what blood sport dude you dude blood
sport is so good I love that
movie but he actually doesn't watch
movies it's
a exactly I just read the Wikipedia
synopsis I get it
pretty good so far someone in the chat
said Alig G for
Wolverine playing L playing Wolverine
hey he's he's a talented actor I could
see him do it he would be really method
about it he would have to have people
call him Logan all the time if you want
somebody who's like Gonna Act the [__]
like I would watch it I don't know if I
would just get uh Daniel de lis to play
wolver yeah there you go I changed my
genetic material to become an actual
mutant somebody somebody had a really
good idea they said jcla vanam could
play me and Robert dairo could play s
okay here's what I want from the chat
here's what I want from you guys if you
guys could assign an actor to play each
of us who would that actor be like I'm
already jeanclaude vanam and Jon
Brothers one of them I'll take God I
would have Dakota Fanning thank you
very she's really talented list yeah
she's I would have Dakota Fanning thank
you Joel Jo will be by about that I
would be Jack Black I know it everyone's
G to say and Joel would be played by
Jack oh they weren't going to say that
but now they are because you said
that was like budget store Jack Black he
was in like uh Balls of Fury and like
all those other comedy movies here's my
question for you who the hell is going
to play a goat head with a blaster
pistol isn't that just Johnny
Depp
shots fired on Johnny DB yeah man
that's Seth Rogan is me H I'll take
it it could have gone worse Bobby Hill
to play Joel you're getting played by a
com somebody said Dwayne Johnson is me
like dude let me tell you something if
the rock wants to play me that's fine
The Rock's like I'm
gonna if the rock wants to read Comics
the read Comics here it comes that needs
to happen my favorite was s would
obviously be played by the guy from
clerks ran o hallerin someone just said
Miley Cyrus for me Joel they're saying
Danny DeVito For You Miley cus I could
see you similar
hairstyles did we want to talk about
comics on our next topic which is just
quickly sorry can I just throw out a
name for Wolverine even though he
probably wouldn't do it Tom Hardy oh
that's not a bad call
he would do it and then quit halfway
through to find the convergence list for
tomorrow where is it Tom hard's like I
already did one superhero movie thank
you very much yeah yeah exactly yeah I
mean I would love like dude I'd love to
see a Tom Hardy Wolverine I mean it'd be
like but here's the problem if Tom Hardy
were gonna play Wolverine he were going
to be effective it would have to be
rated R I couldn't see it anything other
than he was really good in the drop this
year where he basically plays like a
rocky guy who's like you know like kind
of dumb but really tough but with a good
heart and everything it was like James
gandini's last movie oh I remember keep
stalling I'm looking for the comic list
dude I will tell you I will tell you the
movie that won me over for Tom Hardy
like I was unsure about Tom Hardy I'd
see movies from time to time I saw
Warrior like a friend of mine said you
should go see warrior a warrior so good
like as soon I saw that movie and I was
like oh my God Tom Hardy is solid yeah
as a sports movie cuz you have the
double Underdog situation which never
happens usually it's just one Underdog
this movie had two
underdogs
yeah okay you guys ready okay I think
we're talking convergence convergence
zero came out last week both me and Rob
came out with videos talking about
convergence zero uh Rob was a lot more
in depth mine was like yeah you should
read I also had a video yeah for the
scheduled scheduled out tomorrow at 3 in
the afternoon and I and I guess
technically Joel probably beat us all to
it because they put out like every comic
on Wednesday so that wasn't me for once
after doing two year-long weekly events
I farmed that one out to Matt is what I
did which makes sense because he reviews
Superman and he reviews Injustice and
Earth to and those are going to play Big
Parts in convergence right away so maybe
I made the right choice yeah so okay so
those of you guys who are not up to date
with what's going on with convergence
convergence is the big DC event it's
coming out before Secret Wars and
basically what is happening is we've
discovered that all of the alternate
worlds all these worlds that have died
out have been trapped in bottles various
cities by brainiacs around the entire
Multiverse and they're all being
contained on this planet known as T how
do you pronounce it thought that was the
name of that's the name of the don't
know the name the name of the planet but
the planet also becomes the bad guy the
planet that be kept the planet the
planet is bad guy I guess well it's it's
a it's a sentient planet that it was it
was a planet that was sentient it was
terraformed by Brainiac and it was taken
to place outside of space time anyway TS
is the planet basically yeah it's a
planet but also the main either way okay
so all of this stuff is on this planet
so what we discovered in that first
issue is that Brainiac has gone missing
now I'm not going to lie I didn't finish
Futures End but apparently spoilers
Futures End ends with Brainiac yeah Joe
no it it doesn't even end with Brainiac
Futures End has a non-ending it doesn't
end at all that's oh God thank God I
didn't finish it oh my God the main
Brainiac the one that basically his
disappearing kicks this off he shows up
in Futures End like around issue 40 and
he's like you know I am cthulu Brainiac
I exist out side time and space blah and
he gets defeated by the Adam and Mr
terrific oh okay but not really defeated
they shrink him down using adom teac and
then the adom just kind of like traps
him in a ball and that's where he is
pretty tight actually I like that defeat
that that defeating of Brainiac very
poetic okay yeah he gets in a bottle so
so he's missing now so since he's
missing the planet has decided that it's
going to put all of these worlds against
each other to decide which the strongest
one is and that that's what they're
aiming for right now so it's very much
basically battle world I don't know who
devised their plan first who came first
I'd like to exactly yeah because one you
know marvel ad DC one of them started
this ball rolling with let's make all of
our else worlds fight the idea of taking
like of of making like the outcome of
your Universe result from picking
Champions and having them battle with
each other uh that doesn't necessarily
sound like one company over the other as
much as it sounds like both compan
already I mean where you literally have
like the fate of the universe dependent
on like Champions fight what a stupid
idea wouldn't it be a wonderful twist
that both Secret Wars and battle world
are both backdoor Pilots for a new
Marvel DC B they're Dobe I would pay 8
an issue for that idea then to be like
and now they'll no like for both of them
their last universe that exists is the
is DC and Marvel
just okay so anyway now that s's done
ranting or I'm G to force him to stop
literally 30
seconds uh tomorrow comes out the
official issue one issue one begins with
Earth two now I've read all the way to
the end of World's End and literally
World's End ends with Earth 2 being
destroyed and uh all of the civilians
are now floating through space looking
for a new home and as they say in the
ending we will find out what happens to
the heroes in convergence one in conver
after this right
after this quick break yeah same Earth
time or same Earth two channel same
Earth two Place converges one looking at
the cover opens up with uh what's the
what's the black Superman's name from
that Universe what's his name oh valod
okay valad um Thomas Wayne Batman and
our Green Lantern who is attached to the
green not actually attached to the Green
Lantern power right um by the way for
the record I love Earth 2 and I love the
complete reimagining of all of the
that was the greatest thing that they
came out of the 52 um but yeah so conver
is going to open up with that and if you
haven't been reading Earth 2 or World's
End you may be a little lost but all you
really need to know is the superheroes
of Earth 2 which are extreme variations
of the ones you know from the main DC
Universe are going to be like the
starcast of convergence and those thing
because basically the the tagline is
where do worlds go when they die we just
lost Earth too it like they literally
just ended it then we know exactly where
it's going that was the big takeway line
from TS or Telos the bad guy where he's
like I house cities here from universes
in dead timelines I'm like whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa dead timelines so you
mean to tell me that it's official that
all the universes and all the cities
that show up here are like they're dead
and gone the worlds they belong just the
cities that have survived that's what
he's claiming yeah so now because of
this now we don't know how these
timelines work we don't for all we know
I mean we're getting comics in some of
these timelines right now we don't know
how far in the future the whole Brainiac
thing is the whole Brainiac time World
thing is kind of removed from time very
confusing technically two guys were
supposed to make the jump to Future's
end which is five years in the future
right from where we are now it's very
much like the the new Gods where they
kind of like they're a part of
everything and nothing at the same time
they're there but they're not that
situation so one of the big things is
coming out of it and I think you
mentioned it but not only do we have
Earth 2 being heavily influenced into
the convergence event but also the
Injustice Universe did not see that
coming yeah I did not see that coming at
all I thought there was
I totally saw that coming but I was
surprised that it took so long for them
to announce it volumes how popular that
series is both the comic and I guess the
game although I think the comic was
actually more popular
way okay so so Mr Sunday movies we're
gonna go ahead and give you a chance to
talk now finally since Vinnie usually
just won't shut up once he starts
talking and neither will sell I was just
explaining no no here
we you can talk what you want I'm going
to leave I'm out bye guys people are
people are still running off actors and
for like us as people and like somebody
said
like Rob take that take that while you
can I am taking that I'm getting all the
best looking people to play me and that
is so awesome okay so anyway so so Mr
Sunday movie so so what's your thoughts
on the whole convergence thing thus far
or he just not look to be h no no look
I'm I'm all for it I mean not all for it
I mean it's happening so I've kind of
you know settled into it I I've accepted
that these things happen every few years
or whatever but it seems they now come
with more they're more regular than what
they used to be this used to be like a
once in a lifetime or once in a
generation thing and like
it's I think it's it's it's great for
you know people coming on board because
as soon as this is finished you know
then you'll get a whole lot of new issue
ones I guess which is good for new
people but again it's a slap in the face
to everybody who was reading everything
prior like like how people felt with the
new 52 and also do you think this could
be better than flasho do you know what I
mean like I feel like flasho is at least
kind of more accessible if somebody just
picked up convergence issue zero' be
like what the [__] is this oh you got
know a lot of DC hisory I think this
what DC thinks is like an answer to that
I think they're like whereas you know uh
flasho was very like new reader like
open book kind of thing conversions is
for those die in The Wolves DC fans I
mean look at all the Golden Age stuff
we're getting you you're welcome yeah I
mean right yeah I mean going off the
point that these reboots happen every
few years or so I mean that is true to
the point that we've even now got like
so is it a reboot like Crisis on
infinite hers or is it a reboot like
zero hour reboot yeah or or is it like a
flasho reboot I me well it's isn't it
some Comics are staying the same so like
some are continuing and some are issue
ones like so yeah
so not change in any
way to go with what you're saying about
this being for the old and Mr Su too
about this being for the old readers I
mean the convergence Superman 1 which is
on coming out tomorrow is pre flasho
Superman the classic Superman that
everyone loves with his red under on the
outside mared to Lois Lane and she
pregnant but see here you have to look
at it for what it is though and this
this is see this is the issue that I
think a lot of people who are like
looking to get into convergence have is
they say okay like Marvel Secret Wars
we've got three years worth of buildup
which DC doesn't have and like it's all
going to come to a head like on May 2nd
I think which is when Secret Wars number
one comes out free comic book day so
make sure you guys check that out and um
that's basically Marvel's saying okay
we're just going to Multiverse whatever
we all know at the end of the day this
is designed to basically tie everything
into the movies so yeah DC's convergence
is nothing like that DC's convergence
was just like like DC coming along and
saying okay look I know we rebooted
everything with new 52 a lot of you
older fans are pissed off so here's like
six months or two months or however long
it is here's just like old stuff and
it's just for you guys and then once
once convergence is done like all
they're doing is saying okay like once
converence is done we're going to change
some things but the new continuity that
was established with the new 52 is
staying like that's not going anywhere
it's just yeah money was spent so for
the record convergence has been hyped up
a lot longer than just for six months
and Secret Wars has only been hyped up
in like three books for the last three
years yeah but they're all the same guy
like he's been writing the same story
for the last three years it's not like
not like Marvel's been hyping up Secret
Wars in Spider-Man or Daredevil or the
Hawkeye book or the Magneto book they've
been doing in Avengers and New Avengers
both written by Hickman yeah to be fair
and to be fair while the new 52
continuity is staying it's also not
staying simultaneously because DC saying
like we're
not continuity anymore well no but I me
like the origins of Superman after
convergence are going to be the new 52
Origins I mean if when convergence ends
unless they don't want it to that's what
they're
saying you know what that that emo
Superman that all you complained about
gone that one you Lo from pre point he's
back go to his
origin coming back Ian maybe they look
at oh go ahead I mean if they're doing
creativity over continuity maybe we
might end up getting someone that likes
red and blue Superman
in no no no no one lik but but what I'm
saying though is like because I mean you
like to say that they didn't hype this
up very much but I've been reading new52
almost every issue I mean almost some of
the stupid crap I didn't read but um but
if you've been reading the DC stuff a
lot of it has been hping up for
something like this to happen a lot of
it related to Booster Gold over the
years we've gone through it all started
with the Trinity War where we were like
there's more the Multiverse is coming
back what's going on you know and then
we had the various other things popping
up Booster Gold started seeing stuff
Booster Gold met his pre New 52 flasho
an no no no no no I don't I don't mean
they haven't hyped it up in the sense
that they haven't told us it's coming
and they haven't said things are going
to change I don't mean like that I mean
in the sense that like with Hickman's
New Avengers it was okay guys look like
realities are ending and it's going to
culminate in this there's no equivalent
in DC Comics of what Brainiac was doing
while he was going through and capturing
worlds like there's not a singular story
following him it's just there's all
these other stories and he's kind of in
the background and you see him from time
to time but that's it let's not kid
ourselves here this whole convergence
event there's a very practical reason
for why this is happening and I was even
joking about this with s and that is it
is a placeholder event to tie the DC
staff of writers over while they make
the big move from their offices in New
York to their new offices in La they
just set the Roomba on and then clean
the house while they went on vacation
like okay that'll that'll event will
keep them happy until and that's why I
love Jimmy Patti because all all the
books that came out this week are like
hey what happened next to this character
find out in two months after convergence
but palotti is like hey everyone what
happened to Harley and the Gang of
Harley H wait about two months while we
change offices and I'll tell you that
he's like no I don't have to I don't
have to make it's true
I will give you this because convertis
has been hyped up if you've been
following the new2 it's been hyped up in
multiple books and it's being mentioned
and this type of thing has been
happening for a while now but I will
give you this thing it feels to me more
like DC's going into convergence and
their attitude is what works will stay
what doesn't work won't we'll figure it
out as we're going and Secret Wars is
kind of like we know what we're going to
do afterwards hope you like it
yeah well Marvel like definitely seems
to have a plan and the end plan well and
I agree with you because like DC's
convergence it feels like they've been
hyping up to it but they didn't even
fully know what they were going to do
they were like it's going to be a
multivers has a track record of not
having a plan like d already were like
hey this flasho event is gonna be kind
of fun yeah and then you know and then
he fixes everything what if he didn't
fix everything we have a month and a
half what if we did a crisis right now
and people were like okay and then
everyone's bit about it for the last
four years but like yeah they have the
track record of like oh and guess what
it made us boatloads of cash not
planning like it was it's like the kid
who stays up until 2 in the morning and
then realize he has a paper dude the
next day and then gets an A on like oh I
guess I've learned a lesson I don't have
to freaking work very hard on this
stupid course well no but I mean but
it's okay it makes sense if they're
going to okay we know that they're
canceling a whole bunch of books they're
retitling books things like that now why
some of the books that are coming out I
don't like red hood and Arsenal but
nonetheless like yeah some of the books
we're getting is is kind of weird got to
eat I mean I I I agree with you that
like like the new 52 like you guys have
said before DC was just kind of taking
ideas and throwing them and just kind of
seeing what what's what lasts what
sticks or whatever and that seems to be
going for it which is not a bad idea but
here's the problem if DC says okay guys
like here's like all the versions let's
let's say for example that what Brainiac
said or what was being told to Superman
in convergence number zero wasn't
accurate and that Superman isn't dead
and like not every version of Superman's
Dead there's just like some that are
still there we just haven't seen them
yet we don't know who they are or even
some of the ones that we thought were
dead are still alive whatever the case
may be if they took like like right like
pre flas Point Superman right before
they rebooted new52 or they came out
with new52 if they introduce him and
they say all right guys here's this
version of Superman like which one do
you like better that one or flasho well
it's obvious at that point like you've
got zillions of DC readers who all loved
pre flasho Superman and then you have
like a handful of people who are just
now getting into DC with new 52 they're
clearly outnumbered so
that really that's if anything it would
just seem like DC saying okay guys like
here's here's a choice between which one
you want and let us know which one you
think is most popular you know hint hint
nudge nudge you know and then yeah and
then pre- flash point Superman suddenly
post convergence and that's that so but
does pre flasho Superman have a solar
flare power can he do that for the
record I mean I I like the New 52
Superman I do I like I like I think he's
gotten a lot more character development
than the old one did but the old one had
his place he was the icon the idol you
know this is what you should be as a
superhero and I like him I do but I do
like the fact I I feel like the new 2
got more room to grow because they
started him as this early emo guy who's
like I want to L slave but I can't
have he was a little Spiderman in the
beginning he he was a little Spiderman
yeah I mean my whole issue of like going
off as Superman my whole issue with the
new 52 super boy was that he was know
because pre new52 super boy he didn't
care what you thought of him he was fun
and then new52 super boy was just I'm
super boy and I'm sad for no reason and
they gave me a Tron outfit that I'll
wear
everywhere and then my evil doppelganger
stole my body for a bit and I gave up on
that story what when I opened up the
issue and it was like 50 super boys
holding down super boy and telling him
that he needed to be a hero I'm like
nope I I finished the series a like a
few months after it actually finished
and I was reading it literally going I
don't know why I'm reading this this is
terrible I could be doing so many in
Teen Titans annual he's back again yeah
Well's got blood on his head yeah he is
yeah he is but and what was with that
Team Titans annel I could go off on a
round that you know what let's do that
for a second because I went halfway
through that thing and I'm like
nope okay first off first off there's a
Clarion in it but it's not Clarion but
it is Clarion but it's not Clarion from
the Clarion what and Clarion is part of
Manchester Black's new version of the
elite which is Clarion Kid Flash
Guardian Jim Harper oh yeah he's Elite
that dude that dude is the spitting
image of a guy who's Elite and then some
other people in Manchester black wants a
power girl and Wonder Girl to join his
new team like oh we're going to fight uh
the other Teen Titans cuz I'm basically
building Young Justice team kind of sort
of Manchester black makes no sense in
that series like I fund the team and I'm
also kind of on the team but I'm also
transparently evil I love I love how
Joel is doing like an offensive like
accent with Europeans in I just caught
on to that I'm just looking at F's face
and either he's upset about the whole
Teen Titans animal or he's like what the
you here is technically English F you're
Scottish and Mr Sunday You're Australian
so true it's fine so both of you
technically have a lot have a big gripe
against the English anyway
so we can all be right people who aren't
here from that country fine exactly no
once we get an actual Englishman on you
know we'll we'll we'll knock off the uh
the
Cockney okay my co-host Tom and I'll get
him on no I was
done uh I'm just looking at F's face get
worse and worse as Joel kept
going I was just thinking about the Teen
Time Andel I'm like I don't I I've got
every issue of the team Titans going
right back to the first one in the 1960s
so I have to keep buying it and if I buy
it I have to keep reading it even
Weir is the Teen Titans together beat up
Martian Manhunter in that book which
makes no sense I'm like they can't beat
Martian Man Martian Man Hunter is one of
the most overpowered characters in all
of comic only way have no idea what to
do with the only character I could like
justify be up Martian Manhunter would be
M Martian because she was able to beat
up Supergirl um but she's ain't she
ain't on the team the only way she's in
the new 52
somewhere the only way that anybody
beats Martian Manhunter is if they write
Martian Manhunter like he's forgotten
his
powers the best line I've ever seen was
in the Blackest Night when Martian Man H
came back to life and he starts
destroying everything and he and he even
says you everyone always forgets I'm
strong as Superman and he like destroys
everything and telepathic and can shape
[__] yeah and can go intangible like you
can't lay a finger on him like if he
didn't want you to that's that's what
that's what I never got like I was going
through a list on because I was I was
looking at different topics and and one
of them was like like 10 superheroes in
DC that are stronger than Superman and
they were like number one was like
Martian Manhunter they were like he can
do everything Superman can't and I was
like okay like he can make himself like
like you can make I guess intangible
yeah so Superman just can't punch him
and I'm like well that
case they fought shape shifts and wraps
around him and he's like God what
now he okay and that's why I saying Miss
Martian could probably be up Martian
Manhunter because she could do
everything Martian Manhunter could do
and she had laser
[Laughter]
eyes always been like she's a white
Martian I lost track of that whole thing
God um she was a white Martian but
didn't rejected her white Mar Heritage
but then in the titans of Tomorrow
storyline her white Martian self went
into her green Martian self for reasons
um and so that gradually turned her evil
but then the white Martian self got out
of her oh those two characters there was
a weird story arc in like the she
basically had split personality disorder
for about five months okay was it two
separate characters or was it like in
her head battling kind of thing it was
sort of in her head but then she learned
how to sick bunnies on her white Martian
self in her mind wait you make it as up
as you go you know he's not it's thas
when we get out of here you need to tell
me the issues because I'm getting those
the next complete story from comic story
and and then she sicked the bunnies on
her mind you can't write this stuff here
Jeff Jones can regarding uh the no
continuity and convergence and kind of
connecting a little bit to Secret Wars
uh if you don't
mind the I had a question regarding that
because like they're saying that there's
no continuity after convergence is over
despite the fact that like the whole
book is steeped in not one but a
thousand it's continuity porn is what it
is yeah exactly um but they're gonna
have like no continuity afterwards I
noticed that that's kind of being
implemented now in Marvel with respect
to to The Rage of original graphic novel
yep y because they're saying technically
there some people are saying and I don't
know if that's an official word from
Marvel if that's just the creative team
that Rage of Ultron is taking place in
the new continuity for Marvel after SE
okay I didn't know that all right yeah
that's what but that but once again like
I will say that with a caveat that says
like that's what I've been that's what
I've heard but I haven't seen Marvel say
like this is new like yeah it's like
it's like we talked about a little while
ago I think honestly both companies have
realized trying to maintain a consistent
continuity is a lot of work and you end
up putting a lot of things that don't
sell when instead you could just put out
stuff you know is going to sell and just
stop dealing with the continuity cor
exactly the sad go on no no no I was
gonna
say bu bub stop Mr Sund goes first he's
guest yeah not out of mine am I going
yeah you're good go go okay I was going
to say I'm sure they just look at the
numbers and they're like well Civil War
still sells and that because that's a
standalone thing or they look at Old Man
Logan like they look at the most
successful comics and whatever they go
okay these are self-contained runs we
can wrap it up in a nice little book you
can read it as a standalone and I think
they're like well we just do that for
everything well that's I mean like
that's kind of where they're headed
right now with that's where they've been
kind of been heading with like with
respect to uh can you write your story
arc in four or 12 issues so that we
cans uh the other thing is is
like Marvel and DC aren't comic book
publishers anymore they are stewards of
stories that have all been written
they're all just pitchmen now uh because
Marvel and DC are owned by two different
movie studio or I'm sorry owned by movie
production Studios and the Harry Potter
of like movie culture yeah I find that
like Marvel doesn't need to make comics
anymore DC doesn't need to make new
stories anymore you literally like
Spider-Man has proven you only needed
two or three graphic novels worth of
comic books for Spider-Man to make six
movies like and they have hundreds of
movies in these in these stories like
you don't you don't have to write a new
Spider-Man story or a new Batman story
for the next 100 years make enough
movies based on that character and I
think they've kind of cut wise to that
and so it's kind of like no continuity
for them is like well no continuity
because we could make original graphic
novels that are like ideas that we have
germinating around that would normally
be an ongoing series but now can be like
a self-contained story which would be
great uhan cons you know but and and the
fact that like they can now say like
well we're just stewards of the stories
that have been written like there's
already a huge I mean most of our
readership remembers those stories we
wrote the ones who don't watch YouTube
channels that explain them and we and so
as a result like we have this Collective
audience who a captive audience if you
will who knows the stories or wants to
know the stories and wants to see them
on Celluloid and so there's really no
incentive for them to make new Comics
anymore like that's kind of my Doomsday
Prophecy for the comic book industry
right now is like that after Secret Wars
after convergence this would be the time
for them to say we're not really making
new Comics anymore like we'll just we'll
just tell like original graphic novels
that have those characters in those
stories but for the most part like like
just stop like all those book are
canceled we know they're just going to
come back like we know they're just
going to be rebranded and put out again
like you're not canceling Batman and
Robin you're just putting out a new
Batman and Robin at the end of the month
like that's kind of how I felt with like
the Earth ones that they've been doing
which are Standalone graphic novels that
lead one on to the next one yeah I
they're great worse yet for those Earth
One books those Earth One books are
pitch books those are those are proof of
concept script treat well Superman Earth
One the first volume that's man of Ste
that that the that is Man of Steel
alternative like I mean the Teen Titans
Earth one I have to say I didn't think
they realize they were writing the team
one they did I didn't even know I know I
thought there were only two Earth ones
that it was Batman and Superman and then
they were they made the Teen Titans and
F it doesn't feel like teen it's cool
but it doesn't feel like teen it was
totally different this like it must have
been an idea that Jeff lamir had kicken
around for like a teen action series
like well I could make it the Teen
Titans though yeah and then like my
whole thing is like eventually like they
will say oh you know we're not really
making Comics anymore but then I also
say eventually this superhero movie TV
show hype bubble is going to burst and
it will burst like overnight then we all
need to find new jobs I know scary don't
say that hey man I have a I have a job
to go back to okay okay so so s s talked
about rage okay so Rick Remer did an
interview with uh comicbook.com and they
asked him the question point blank all
right the question was let's talk about
the story line for a bit blah blah blah
blah blah um how does basically how does
Rage of Ultron tie into continuity and
he's like uh it's high on of the movie
kind of like he didn't give a definitive
answer like like but see then and okay I
get that it ties into the movie but you
know like here comes a clue train
apparently the last stop is Rick Remer
uh Captain America is not Falcon in the
movies
so I mean I don't I don't know I don't
know what he so s's probably right it
seems like it's probably set after
Secret Wars because you've got Captain
Falcon like all new Captain America well
it doesn't even have to be set anywhere
like it could literally just be an
original graphic novel that doesn't have
continuity like people are so they need
it like when does it take place like
doesn't matter it's just a story with
these characters You Know It new
Avengers stories that week that we got a
digital one Rage of Ultron and then I
forget what the other one was yeah and
none of them were their own like all of
them were their own continuities like
and you know what like fine like for me
I love the interconnectivity of the
Marvel Universe it looks like that's
where they're going I don't think the
bad I don't I don't think it's going to
be quite that like CH industry changing
when it's all over but I do feel like
they're going to leave the door open for
when they're like hey you know what like
this universe is its own Universe like
and there's a Spider-Man in this
universe and there's a you know there's
an X-Men in this universe and they're
just not big play you know what I mean
like they're not going to be there's no
616 okay but even though there
apparently will be this is different
though I mean it's not like they're
doing it's not like they're doing like
like the century you know like a well
Marvel Knights Standalone it's not not
necessarily the case because one you've
got Marvel coming along and saying okay
hey guys like like we're resetting our
continuity to a degree like some
characters are going to stay some are
going to go their Origins still are
still the same for the most part at
least it seems to be the case whatever
like we're just changing continuity
getting rid of multi getting rid of
universes making things make sense
consolidating it all at the same time we
have Age of Ultron coming out at the
beginning of May so the question is when
people see a story called Rage of Ultron
and it features cast members or features
characters from the current run of
Avengers and New Avengers and then it
also is designed to address or to
basically give us an idea of what Ultron
in the film is going to be like right
with the exception of the fact that you
know SPO well I won't spoil it for those
who haven't read it but everyone else
spoiled it this way okay so anyway so
the whole Hank Pim thing and you know
whatever but the fact remains that
people are like legitimately confused
when does Rage of Ultron take place is
it Post Secret Wars is it pre- secret
Wars does it not have a continuity it's
one thing if Marvel came out and said
okay guys like there's no continuity
here this is just a standalone story
that has characters that's what they
need to say it if that's the case
instead of beating around the bush
because I think here's here's what I
think is happening they're looking at
Rage of Ultron to see the success
they're looking at Rage of Voltron to
see how well-received it would be if
Ultron if Hank Pim was Ultron basically
and the idea is if it's successful if
people like it that's what's going to
happen to Hank pin when Secret Wars ends
if it's not then they're just going to
totally get rid of it and they're going
to say well it's just a standalone story
that's it don't worry about it and
that's and that's going to be it well
and and and and I agree with you I think
that's part of the problem here is that
we it's blatantly obvious that because
they're being so dodgy about it they
want to see how it's received yeah
because that I think they don't want to
get in bed with anymore and why a lot of
things are changing around and I I was
talking about this in a review that I
haven't put up yet about Batman and
Robin number 40 Robin got powers
everyone hated it and you could
definitely tell that was intended to be
a longer running idea and took it away
instantly yeah like and it got such a
poor response that the story AR just
immediately went back status quo he's
Batman and Robin again yeah he only
mentions it like one more time in the
annual like man I sure wish I had my
Powers now and Batman's like shut up
Damen yeah don't even talk about it
Daman anymore in never had powers we're
moving on from that no one liked that
and it's kind of what I feel like like
there both companies are getting to a
point where they don't want to
definitively State something is in
continuity anymore because if it's not
well received they just want to be able
to just remove it and just be like raise
your vult stand alone so isn't that just
what they did back in the Golden Age
have we just come like full circle
that's exactly what they did there were
there were no CC back in the Golden Age
there were no like there were no like
there was no real shared continuity like
that that didn't exist like you had
Superman stories you had Batman stories
you had Aquaman story you had St like
Wonder Woman stand sometimes they met
each other and sometimes they didn't but
it was never a big shared continuity
thing like what happens in Metropolis is
going to affect what happens in Gotham
that didn't exist and but then that all
changed the Silver age so just kind of
throwing this out there if we've come
full circle we're going back to the
Golden Age everyone's kind of sensitive
now everyone's all about political
correctness are we going to get another
Comics code oh God I don't think
so I don't think I don't think we're
going back to the golden age I think
it's more silver age cuz Silver age when
it launched did this with I mean a great
example of them doing this initially was
The Killing Joke they put it out and it
when it came out it was not clear if it
was in continuity or not they were like
and then it got got so well received now
Barbara Gordon's in a wheelchair go read
Killing Joke cuz that's how that
happened that's true and like fact is
and also like the the the comics code
was a was a consequence of like the
government responding to a Witch Hunt so
and when it was the the comic book
industry being like we'll we'll
self-govern like we'll deal with it
ourselves since there's no like outside
antagonist I don't see them like really
needing to do that yeah um and plus like
with Comics being rated like yeah I
think we're good like I I don't I'm not
I'm not worried about censorship in as
much as I'm worried about like a stupid
Authority saying what to do we're seeing
that in as much as we're seeing like The
Mouse House owns Marvel so no one can
smoke like we're seeing censorship in
that like we're seeing uh like more like
characters getting neutered or undercut
or like you know Spider-Man can't be a
zombie anymore because his children
might read it and then like so that's
kind of what we're seeing like self
censorship as opposed to like I feel
like your Fox News and that it's more
focused on kind of like video games now
like everybody loves comic book movies
so I think this is just going to be left
alone oh comics are like old hat now is
the thing where it's just like you know
we could talk about how the comics are
corrup in the youth but I'd much rather
talk about how the video games and the
internet and the Holograms are corrupted
well not only that but like comic books
what what's the what's the how much does
that industry pull in uh not even a
fraction of the video game industry yeah
I want to get in on some of that uh yeah
that's that's ex but no like with the
whole the whole Rage of Ultron thing to
to kind of finish my thought on this
like I really blame Joe assada because
there was a problem jasada in like 200
whatever it was said no more Marvel
Knights done and done like everything
that shows up now shows up in continuity
and by the way do what that was his idea
Marvel Knights like him and Bill but
what I'm saying is if they if they kept
the Marvel Knights imprint which were
just a serious like in humans volume two
was supposed to be Standalone like it
was supposed to be just a self-contained
in human story and they said nope now
it's continuity and then it's volume two
if they had just like kept the Marvel
Knights imprint and said Marvel Knights
are strictly Standalone stories they
could have released Rage of Ultron
slapped a Marvel Knights imprint on it
and nobody would have asked questions
they would have said oh well stand alone
cool and that would have been it and it
would have been a cool story and people
would have read it just like they are
now but they wouldn't be confused about
where it stands in relation to the movie
or the comics or Secret Wars and all all
that kind of good stuff you know I think
it is too like I mean we're putting all
this thought into it because obviously
that's what we do and that's what people
love us for but but but maybe the answer
is really simple maybe just Marvel's
like hey you know what would be great a
bucket full of comic money to go along
with this bucket of movie money ulton
let's just put out a bunch of Ultron
stuff all at once because we can't
actually do it in like the Avengers
books we have now cuz they're busy
dealing with incursions and our reboot
let's just put out a bunch of Ultron
books and just we just eat it on the
Shelf you know you know what the
funniest part about this whole thing is
like they named the new movie Age of
Ultron and you and they've already made
that story arc like and people who like
that
that Phantom group of people who go see
this movie and then run to the comic
book store and buy all who don't exist
or is like 2% uh are going to go to the
com store they're going to pick up Age
of Ultron super disappointed first of
all there's no Ultron in this book
second of all why is Wolverine going
back in time yeah exactly unsellable so
they have to have a book called Rage of
Ultron it even sounds like Age of Ultron
so people will just be duped and they'll
just buy that graphic is exactly what it
is actually I had a Twitter I tweeted
out that I I I'm reading a rage of volar
on today so I get ready to write get the
story out for next week and I had
someone to respond with you already did
Age of Ultron that is exactly what
they're trying to do go I will I will
admit when I first saw Rage of Ultron my
initial thought was so did Weird Al
write his own version of Age of
Ultron well and that's
C I mean that is 100% right like in
remender's interview he said that
initially um his like the title I think
that he wanted to use was the evolution
of Ultron and then was like nope Rage of
Ultron call it that yeah no one's going
to buy that no one's going to buy that
you know with the level of I don't give
a crap that they seem to be displaying
they might as well just called it Age of
Ultron yeah like I'm shocked they didn't
I'm shocked they didn't call it super
age of ulton New Age of Ultron
meon I mean going back a little bit but
also kind of linking this we we're all
going to saying like how we're in
there's different ages of comics could
it just be like we're going into the new
age of comics this just the I don't give
a crap age of comics because I was just
talking to somebody about this the other
day where I was talking about like gold
silver bronze
modern and I guess just been modern for
the last 50 years like you know like
like like modern art started in like
1918 like and now it has to be something
else like there's you can't just call it
modern because like then what will what
will what's today zc age so let's dub
the new age let's do it let's the the
weekly poll at our guest Mr Sunday
movies and
Joel Joel I call it the new the weekly
pool and Mr Sunday movies what are we
gonna call the new age of comics I think
it should be called the event age yeah
yeah that's a really yeah that's great
because it is it's like this is a big
thing that's happening
yeah call it this is a big thing that's
happening the age where all the things
happen and you guys will really really
like it we really don't care at the end
of the day just give us your money
yeah will ever be the
same I would say the foil age but that
makes me think too much of like Hollow
foils like in the 90s maybe like the
zinc age or something like that age of
zinc let's go with event I like that so
far the event age yeah that's a good you
know what we're g to do whenever we
pitch it I'm going to need you to give
me a recording of you saying it just
like that Mr Sunday so every time we're
like welcome to the event age
go so
okay the digital age sorry
digital age is a good one too yeah but
did digital like did digital change
everything or was it more just like
digital I think it was digital because
if you think about it a lot of these
Standalone more the recent versions of
them because I mean we've always had
Standalone stories but the more recent
ones have turned in initially started
with I least of what I've noticed they
all started as like okay we're going to
do comics online only online only
smaller chapters and then if they do
well there they'll get a comic and if
they do even better they'll get a book
and yeah I would I would also submit the
Celluloid age I mean I I was going to
say the Hollywood age you beat me too we
can't call c age because age because
that sounds way too much like the
cellulite age yeah no but I think like I
mean the digital age probably wouldn't
be the worst thing because I if you
think about it like comixology changed
everything like prior to comicy was like
well I mean I mean prior to them it's
like well I mean I go to go to the store
and have people were like I don't even
know where my comic book store is and
I'm not going to take time because
you're talking about people who want to
know right now like if they can't find
it in like in four minutes or less than
that in like a minute they just don't
worry about
it you know what though think about this
though does anyone still remember that
local grocery stores still have a
magazine section where they have comic
books that's true wait grocery stores in
America had comic books oh yeah people
get their Comics oh dude we got like we
got like full I love when things like
Dawn on F it's so hilarious oh dude like
yeah man I went to I went to Kroger man
like I got I got some asparagus I got
some parsley like I got some salmon I
got some scallops and I got a copy of
World War Z like you you can buy
everything I got I got the whole run of
Bloodlines from a 7-Eleven one oh wow
like books bookstores in the UK have
only recently like in the past 10 years
started selling manga like they still
don't really sell Comics but there's
like a section for manga cuz that's
pretty big here and even then it's like
two shelves and they're like look our
new expanded manga all the manga that is
wherever will'll be is right in these
two shells speak it's all Full Metal
Alchemist and attack on D narut it's
actually pretty good like they have some
good stuff like like saem Moon there you
go all right I'm gonna take this as a
moment to segue over because we are now
going out fish hour and we still have
one more topic guys so Mr Sunday movies
us what's happening
Friday um well I don't know other than
you get a space shuttle and I still have
to get you a
it's true well Friday well actually it's
it's Saturday for me but uh basically
what it is big event Netflix series the
Daredevil is coming 13 uh 13 ST stand
alone no 13 interconnected stories
connected to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe yep yeah all new Daredevil
story I'm I'm I'm very excited like I
still can't believe that it's this week
like it's crazy feel like it's kind of
snuck up yeah it like a Christmas
present we're all going to wake up and
open it I'm really I'm really hoping
that like they tie in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe tally like I wanted
to focus on Daredevil but I want to see
like Matt Murdoch in his office or like
getting coffee or something like that
and like like on a news blip on a TV
screen they're like shields in total
disarray have you heard the uh did you
see the trailer where they referen them
I I didn't see that there's a moment in
one of the teasers where they say
something like well you don't have like
a IND indestructible Shield or a magic
hammer you're like oh what
I mean I just got done reading Dr yell
today to get the video off Friday and
half I mean not half but a good chunk of
that is him referencing other
superheroes like him constantly stating
he's like it'd be so cool if eventually
people were like Spider-Man Thor
Daredevil you know he's you know I I
know I'm not Spider-Man and Fantastic 4
so someone has to take care of the
street thugs because they can't do it
the bit that I liked is where it's like
how are they going to justify this Frank
Miller inspired gritty New York setting
in a modern time tell you something and
the reason for that is is that they said
oh chitari Invasion that's why New York
went to hell again after the Alien
Invasion yeah let me tell you something
the moment oh sorry I was just you're
fine go ahead man okay there's a moment
from Frank record I'm interrupting now
because I just want to say when you two
interrupt each other it's hilarious you
both get super apologetic I just jump in
and talk but you're both my bad my
bad did you I'm sorry for interrupting
man oh
no I was a little overzealous I
appreciate it so the thought was um in
Frank Miller's run of Daredevil where uh
The Avengers actually show up I think
that's kind of the reality we're going
to get we're it's just this moment where
uh Daredevil's beating the hell out of
some guy some informant I can't remember
and then the and like there's a there's
a fire going out of control and then the
Avengers show up and they're all cast in
Shadow and they just look like these
intangible like very incredibly
disconnected characters like it's
literally Thor cap and Iron Man and they
show up and they like rescue everybody
and dar just beating this dude like he
just like and it's all and it's raining
and there's like lightning and Thor's
commanding it and then like and then
Iron Man shows up and he's like you got
to hand over the dude like you got to
hand over that guy he's like he's an
Avengers like he's under our
jurisdiction we got to have him and like
Daredevil's like I could smell his
Repulsor starting to like fuse up like
they're ready to go like Iron Man's
ready to throw down with me and I'm
going to
die and I'm like yes I want that
Daredevil that's amazing I think that
we're going to get that like especially
if they make it really gritty with Civil
War absolutely I mean it's great to see
something like like a down in the dirt
street level just like just taking
beatings every night and dishing him out
you know I mean like he's not like a guy
who lives up in a tower and he has like
coffee breaks or whatever Butler won't
be telling him like what the probability
of his success will be yeah exactly like
he gets teeth knocked out and he gets
like it's just amazing I moment from the
first trailer where they that in cutting
that like really frenetic moment where
he's just like ready to go he's right
he's standing outside the door and then
he just goes like he just goes in like
he's
ATP oh like the like The Raid 2 which is
like the best action movie of the last
couple
years I mean that was that was my big
thing when they because my big like I
mean to to capitalize what s said like
for those of you guys who haven't read
Daredevil or ar aren't too where
Daredevil one like I have a video up
about where to start with Daredevil um
yeah Benny will have his video about
Daredevil like we're all going to have
videos about Daredevil Frank Miller's
Daredevil Frank Frank Miller's Daredevil
is like the defend yeah if it's a
contest we can make it a contest um oh
that's it contest has been initiated who
will contest Daredevil contest daredevil
isev videos yep wa for the wait hold on
hold on we have to state that Joel and C
Cast are not in the contest cuz they
have more people than us and they will
win by
people me tell every we also have to
disqualify F because he uploads the
least and we don't want him to have to
try and kill himself so all right so so
it's me S Binny and James okay cool I
don't even
know okay but watch now I'm just going
to pull out the best Daredevil video
it's going to have musical
numbers musical numbers D devil deil
we're all going to cry at the it's like
that's beautiful you moved midgets
dressed as
yeah where do you live Wonderland o o i
o but no for for those of you guys who
are are not familiar with Daredevil out
there and that are watching this
watching this live stream which thank
you for for tuning in um Frank Miller's
Daredevil is the quintessential
Daredevil like like anybody who ever
says what should I start with Daredevil
immediately the answer is read Frank
Miller's Daredevil and then decide what
you want to do after that because Frank
Miller like
change your pants yeah I mean he he made
him like he made him dark he made him
gritty like he made him like a character
that was just down to the ground and
that's what I'm really really hoping
stays with Daredevil because my biggest
fear here is Marvel saying okay like
these are going to tie into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and somewhere down
the line whether it's a year from now
two years from now or something like
that like Luke hay Jessica Jones
Daredevil Iron Fist they're going to
move away from like this gritty street
level kind of thing and they're going to
move up to the upper echelons of the
Avengers real and they're going to you
know be fighting alongside Tony Stark
and it's not going to be as dark and
gritty as what we're going to get with
the beginning of the series I doubt
it'll get that way but that was my
initial concern is is how that would
start but once they said like we're
doing Frank Miller's Daredevil I was
like okay I'm sold like I'm I'm so
excited to see this because it's gonna
be it's gonna be
awesome about that is that if they play
their cards right season one can be
Frank Miller season two can be Bendis
then Brew Baker and then you play it up
like that every season is a new riter
that's such a good idea
do Shadowland yeah no and Skip Kevin
Smith I'm G throw out there and you guys
can be mad at me all you want but I'm
not a fan of almost any Kevin Smith run
on anything because I like his Green
Arrow and I like and I enjoyed his
Daredevil I was I didn't think it was
like oh this changes everything I was
just kind of like oh it was fun I like
the guy I like a lot he's done I'm just
not a fan of his writing I like him more
than his Batman I
mean
Jesus I mean I defin agree with you
Benny I'm just not a fan of his
stuff and every time I hear the name
Kevin Smith now there was a SE there was
the scene in the first season of king of
nerds where this girl was crying going I
know stupid Kevin Smith I know loads
about Batman I can't take the man
seriously now because I just picture
that every time I hear Kevin Smith I I
genuinely like Kevin Smith but I feel
like he's too much of a fan to write
certain
characters he's so caught up and like oh
my God ring Batman I can do anything oh
my God like you know what I mean it's
just look at my
friendman yeah no I I agree with you I
do I I I like he Smith's work I like his
movies I like stuff he does but whenever
he seems to write a comic book I always
get a feeling of it's it would be like
if someone gave me Batman said Benny go
write Batman I would just be
like I feel like he writes exactly I
feel like like it feels
fanfictiony I feel like that's a bit
rude to say but you're right you're
right and I can hear his voice I'm like
that's Kevin Smith dressed as Batman
like saying you know what I mean that's
how I say it like every time that I I
read a Kevin Smith comic I hear it in
his voice when he whenever you hear his
stand up and he talks about that
Superman movie he was on yes and I hear
that voice coming through like when he
talks about his anal Fisher
yeah so I do want to State real quick
while we have a free moment uh F the
audience would like you to start a
Kickstarter to get [__] to dress like
Daredevil
wow I'm throw five bucks in that I got
five on that one D by the way I
got I am uh I am from New Jersey I've
met Kevin Smith a few times Kevin Smith
is of course great and I would like to
be on uh I would like to on SMC one day
I mean definitely you know I mean with
Kevin Smith and his his fantastic show
um which is probably one of the best
shows on television at the moment and
his superb writing in comic books Uh
Kevin Smith if you happened to see this
you know we would love to have you on uh
we you
imagine goat head just have Kevin
Smith's head in the middle kind of
gosh yeah Hey Kevin Smith loves Canada
so there's a chance that I might be able
to meet him if he ever does that yoga
hosers thing that he's talking about
okay two seconds two has anybody seen
his latest movie Tusk no no don't watch
it okay any movie I deliberately didn't
see it I like Kevin Smith movies which
is why I didn't see it there you go I
watched it I'm not I stole it I
torrented that one I'm like I don't want
to pay anything because it's a man
turning into a
walrus I heard the podcast that was on
like I heard the story I heard that
episode too I was like well no don't do
it though lots of crazy stories but yeah
but it's not like yeah no no my issue
really is just he he really let Zack and
mu's failure turn him into his career
like into what he is now like his
dependency on marijuana is so sad like
it really like frustrates me as like as
a you know supposed artist like I feel
really bad for him and I need to be in a
soft bubble with only my fan base I'm
not even G to screen my thing for the
big mean critic I know his fan base
getting smaller like you know
that okay um I'm I'm sorry guys like I
need to I need to stop this conversation
for a second and tell you guys like
we're at 53 viewers right now one
of Kevin Smith I mean I just
okay I'm sorry um I'm sorry James go
ahead continue your
thought let's move this back let's move
this back let's go back to our topic of
Daredevil and get off of how bad Kevin
Smith's life's getting I don't know how
we got on that topic for the for the
record I don't feel bad for him at all
because he's like Filthy Rich and you
know whatever a hot wife so there you go
yeah yeah his life is pretty cool I mean
like he's
the his move on move on we're going to
DAR
yeah we can't we can't let it go buddy
let it go buddy but but but in any event
um I think I think that that the
Daredevil series like Marvel launching
the Daredevil Netflix series more so
than the fact that it's going to be dark
and you know I think is a great change
of pace because as great as the Marvel
movies are at the end of the day they're
starting to kind of grow a little bit
stale because how often can you really
have some great big huge Earth
shattering event or how often can
Captain America really go against Shield
before you get to the point where you're
like uh okay I mean the writing many
times as we need to I mean I mean I mean
the writing will be good the movies will
be great but I love the idea and this
this is what I think a lot of people
like I love the idea of street level
characters I love the idea of a guy that
has a gun and his wits and that's all he
needs to like be a superhero and that's
that's why I think made Punisher cool
that's why I think that Luke Cage was
cool I think that's why Jessica Jones
well Jessica Jones was she went through
a lot of [__] but nonetheless
like she's seen some stuff we don't have
time to get into that that's
that's rest assured for those of you
guys who are unsure about the Jessica
Jones Netflix series you will not be
disappointed there will be some I hope
it's great ask Bas on what you just said
because this i' reading a lot of
Daredevil lately does he actually have a
gun yeah yeah wait Daredevil
no well no I mean when I say like a gun
in his wits I mean just you know like
your guy who's because he does there are
scenes where he has a gun but I've
always thought he grabbed the goons gun
you know no I mean I mean he my trusty
gun Golden Age Batman call it he has I
mean he has he has a I mean he has like
Daredevil has a gun I mean Matt Murdoch
has a gun like I mean they've shown it
in the comics before like if you go read
like some of the max imprints where he
pops up or something like that like he I
mean not he won't use it go after people
and like shoot them like gun them down
in the
street but he has but he has a weapon
I'm dared of a
[__] criminal should go ganger DED Z SN
you he'll shoot over your head wouldn't
wouldn't that be like a crazy like like
a Marvel Max imprint where like you turn
the page and Daredevil just like shoots
a guy in the back of the head I
mean just be extreme he say I'm
Daredevil [__]
like allar Daredevil am I I'm
Daredevil bullets with his bill billy
club he has done that they they should
they should they should do they should
launch like all new all different
Daredevil and just like he KS people
with guns you know it's funny you should
say that cuz like Mark Wade on the book
right now I get the feeling he knows his
time on that book is numbered and
they're going to change it to match the
show so he's like fine then I'm going to
do everything I've ever want he's going
to have a suit and a Hollywood haircut
and you can't stop me but Mark Wade's
Daredevil is not even bad either like
it's good I enjoy it yeah and what like
what if we take this poor character who
has a worse life than Peter Parker and
just give him like a half moment of
Happiness give him a little bit of
something editorial snatch away to make
more like the TV show yeah I mean the
main thing that worries me about like
all the TV shows going on to like more
sort of a more realistic approaching on
street level and I've been saying this
for a while a long while most of the
people that watch my show will know this
my favorite area in comics as much as
they talk about the teen tit and stuff
is like that I really like the teen tit
and they're one of my favorite teens but
my favorite area in comics is stuff like
the Doom Patrol and like '90s Vero stuff
where it was just weirdness and it was
dark but it wasal but it was still like
off like it was still like it was very
like magic realism where you're like oh
like this is kind of weird like
it's version of reality yeah it was like
commentary on our world but it was weird
as [__] and you like the person that
wrote this had to be twisted and then I
know for a fact they tried making a
movie about death from Sandman and they
said they they had to stop it in um
pre-production because they're like we
just don't know how who this would
appeal to because oh it's true and I'm
they can't make a movie about death from
Sandman one of my the most relatable
charact they're not anymore they they're
making they're making Sandman so death
will appear but I think they are on I
think they are still working on Sandman
which what which scares me even more
because death was the most relatable
character in Sandman if they can't do
death how the hell are they gonna do
Morpheus no it's true and yeah no it's I
love it with f go in these rants because
he's just he's might blowing up as he
he's like how the
hell wa minute see look at this look
somebody said you guys should do a
13-hour live stream watching the
Daredevil series I told you we should do
that Benny I told you and I told you I
wouldn't I I didn't say it was a bad
idea I'm just you and will do this like
we we will I'm down dude I will hit you
up I'll hit you up on like Friday or you
want to hang out with them for 13 hours
if we did it like because I was planning
on doing like a 12 hour long charity
live stream could we just merge it with
that let's do it man should each pick a
charity and do that I say you guys
because I have a freaking
job okay fine then we we'll do it we'll
do it on Saturday and like you can hang
out with you can volunteer to watch TV
with you all day not you not you you
said I have other friends
storylion views and you're 100,000
subscribers you can just sit on a pole
things to do on Saturday actually yeah
I'm kind of busy I have a lot of f
talking out he's like hey here's how
this is gonna work so you guys are gonna
you and Joel Rob and Joel you guys can
watch Daredevil for 12 hours by the way
can we just flag it as it's super
effective charity stream I'll be not
there
but we'll have a cut out what we'll have
you know you can do actually this is
just us this is literally just a just a
weekly poll meeting now but like we
could legitimately just do a live stream
where it's 13 hours and people drop in
and out like just people pop in awesome
like tag team like a tag in yeah like
it's episode four comic story it's
coming in or like episode seven Here
Comes comp do that like like can I be
drunk no you can't be drunk I mean like
we really have you'll be drunk It's
episode 10 and the comic story is a
little tipsy okay look look you can be
drunk so long as I can do this stream as
I plan to do it when it's new in my robe
with a big bowl of
cereal no but you're only allowed to do
that if you say nothing for the whole
first
episode the light only light in the room
must be from the TV okay so so Mr Sunday
movies are you are you down for being
part of this
look it depends it's look if I'm fre
absolutely definitely okay okay I
thought be like Mr Mr Sunday movies is
sitting there like God damn it I just
said I'll be on a podcast and you just
for 12 hours you DED what the hell is
wrong with you and now we're all moving
in together and we're buying a time
share you get me a visa to move to the
US no like moving in with s he's got
room we should we should like in all
seriousness in all seriousness we should
do like that's not know that's an
awesome idea like like I mean I I I can
start it whatever like or we should just
do it on Twitch or on the on the weekly
P hit box wherever it is we end up doing
it like we should I'm doing I'm saying
this as your friend you you need Hobbies
outside of comics buddy oh I do have
hobbies outside of comics I'm saying
like watch TV shows based on comic like
TV this this is an awesome this is an
awesome idea we should for as long as
I've known you all you do is read comics
and vape man and I think vape's not
doing it for you anymore oh was doing it
you have no idea yeah like oh oh dude
Joel let me tell you something man like
like ask Vinnie and S what happens when
I don't get E Juice so like here here is
here's what we should do that'll be our
that'll be our post show discussion for
every discussion we here's what we
should do we should I think s's idea is
right like like we should launch the
live stream and then the first hour like
somebody sits in and then the second
hour somebody shows up the third hour
some somebody different each hour and
then yeah unless you have two people who
are dedicated to do it like f want to do
like a charity live stream where it's
like it's the it's the Daredevil charity
for like blindness or something
dude has a
charity and Rob and Joel will be there
for the whole 12 hours oh
yeah other people and comic book cast is
huge so I mean like I we've got like a
dude in Britain and Australia we've got
people we can take the night shift and
stuff it'll be c yeah like we we'll get
this worked out once the show's
over anyway I'm gonna tell the story
about Comic Con and Rob not vaping no no
we we'll yeah we're doing it we're doing
it I'm going to tell we're not doing it
now early everyone's going to be like
what happened to the store okay guys
this podcast is coming to an end we will
catch you guys in peace I got I gotta
close it all right guys so as usual
thank you for joining us today today if
you were coming in late and you want to
watch the the show post after all of
this uh today we talked about
convergence we talked about the new
daredevil show and we talked about what
did we open with oh Wolverine and
end we didn't tell you about the books
you can expect from convergence tomorrow
but that's okay you'll go to the store
you'll find them we got halfway through
that we're fine uh
so as usual I'm Benny the comic storian
it's YouTube back whatever comic storian
f is it's super effective it's it's
yours is not it's super effective it's
like super effect like what if you type
in
youtube.com C SL it's super effective it
works okay okay s is now comic pop not
TV little house even though it still
says TV Little House on Rob's
Skype hold on what oh it
does I need to fix that and then Rob as
you guys know cuz you're on his channel
as Comics explain Mr Sunday movies and
Joel are two guests of the day who are
not normals but but Joel rotates in
quite often Mr Sunday movies is welcome
to but Mr Sunday movies does great
videos on all comic books and and movies
and he does facts um one of the big
things that I enjoyed on his channel was
things you didn't notice in the trailer
because I didn't notice them so it was
fun until all these things turn out to
be not true and then people will attack
me like that's dude I and for those of
you guys who have not caught Joel on an
earlier podcast Joel is from the comic
book cast a crew like 20,000 people who
talk about comic books every week we're
basically the wuang clan of comics
everyone everyone's a member and you
don't even know it's like I thought they
were a member but I I mean I okay I want
to be considered like an honorary member
of the comic book cast totally well he's
he's the we requires just that everyone
in the chat is also now a member of com
I like Bendis when he wrote The Avengers
everyone gets to be an Avenger
now by the way like when they were
saying um out so like I've already sent
him over to the entire comic book cast
guys
so card this is the weekly poll you know
that that that free comp day book where
like Kamala Khan is an Avenger and
everybody and they were like guess what
everybody Miles Morales is gonna be an
Avenger it's like saying guess what
everybody Miles Morales and comic and
Kamala Khan are Marvel characters like
yeah everyone's an Avenger man moonight
was an Avenger it's over that's that's
that's really how I felt I felt like I
felt like Bendis could have just like
been walking down the street he was like
hey you homeless guy like you want to be
an Avenger he's like scruffy we an
Avenger
nowr so so yeah everybody oh my I'm
never gonna end
this guys getting back at me this isn't
gonna work it's the start of the 13-hour
stream throw it I don't know so like
have you see that amazing sketch where
Nick Fury shows up at the end of other
people's
movies well well well no I
toh
G that's what I expect like Nick FY
being like you're an Avenger now and so
are you you Tom all right so anyway
anyway guys real quick thank you all for
joining us today we will be back next
Tuesday right now AIS from variant
Comics may be joining us we're a little
unsure his schedule May conflict if
that's the case he'll come on the
following podcast but you can expect us
to be here next Tuesday talking about
convergence and all the stuff and if we
hated or liked Daredevil if you if we
end up doing that Daredevil charity
stream I'm sure Rob will have it posted
everywhere so you'll be able to track it
very easily and for those of you guys
who are wondering all of us here except
for Mr Sunday movies body's welcome to
be an honorary member or a member of the
weekly pool.net it is a website for all
of the comic book channels that talk
about comic books we have a community
there we have forums we have our Twitter
everything is up and running and we
would love it if you guys would go over
there and check it out uh go to the
weekly pool.net it is right there we
rotate articles and everything like that
uh that is push for convergence by the
way huge bunch of AR doing we got a huge
planned thing for convergence it's going
to be amazing we want you guys to be
there chatting about this in forms
chatting with us we all do go check
there some of us more often than others
f i I posted last week and like I got
one
reply so uh but yeah make sure you go
check out the website uh everything is
looking good over there guys we would
love it if you come and join us that is
the weekly poll podcast which eventually
when we stop being lazy will move to a
live stream service yep oh um also guys
uh those of you viewers don't forget um
as usual you will find Mr Sunday movies
Channel down in the description of this
video so if you guys are familiar with
him why you wouldn't be but you guys
should check it
out Al before Rob can end the podcast
I'm going to explain what happened com
how we learned how we learned he doesn't
work well vaping oh my God so if you
want that that's it we're talk done
talking about Comics but I'm G give you
five minute story so bitching in the
chat about oh my God if you really want
tell if you really want to tell the
story man just tell the freaking story
I'm telling it I'm telling it so me S
and Rob are all at ComicCon right now I
go to a bunch of conventions I've been
doing this now for for a couple years s
goes to a bunch of conventions Rob is
not really experience so we go to this
first convention s and I are kind of
beining doing the work thing we're going
huge by the way it's New York ComiCon
it's like the second largest convention
in the country
like I'm gonna try it out I'm gonna I'm
gonna get my feet wet with the biggest
convention in the East yeah so Rob's
defense he did pick the largest one like
we all get there Rob's like I'm just
gonna check it out I'm gonna walk around
today and Rob did not bring his vaping
tools he thought he could make it the
weekend without vaping greatest idea
he's ever had so s and I go off we start
working we start working we start
working Rob gets like two hours into it
and and he's now walked the entire floor
he's checking the whole thing out and we
now realize Rob doesn't do as well
without vaping Rob needs vaping to be
chill Rob so as the days goes on Rob
starts to get more and more irritable
which is now irritating me and St who
have been running around so we're all
getting irritable like me and style are
like godamn we're working our butts off
getting interviews and crap and Rob's
just sitting over there and Rob's like
go screw yourselves I know I haven't
Vaped all day you all can just burn hell
wrong smash it was rough it was a very
so if we get to the end of the entire
thing everyone's on edge everyone's
arguing we're all still buddies but like
in a friendly arguing kind of way we get
in the car and and Style's like you want
me to bring you somewhere to vape you
want me to go get you some tools we can
go pick up some stuff H yeah now now
here's here's the other half here's the
other half of the story all right what
Benny is telling you guys is just a as a
wh full of lies all right he's he's
lying l to compound to compound my lack
of vaping I wore the most uncomfortable
shoes I could possibly wear and so my
feet were killing me so so here's so
here's Rob at New York ComicCon two
hours first con ever I will give you
that first real con first con ever all
right I'm a drama queen oh my God my
feet hurt man this is man this sucks
like I was I was and then on top of that
I had no nicotine in me so I was if if I
If I Were Gay I'd be a raging [__] like
that's that's exactly what it was like I
was that's all yourself sure you were a
raging
[__] it the end of the first day we're
driving around we're all trying to pick
out restaurants to go eat Rob gets in an
argument with me about the MC rib and
whether or not it's a real rib he's like
they have all the ingredients I don't
understand why they don't just give it
to
me and the kicker is like I'm sitting
there trying to explain to him what a MC
rib is and he's just he's so irritable
and so like just like in pain that he's
just like screw you Benny it's real rib
I don't care what you say it's a real
rib I remember that that was bizarre is
no it's not not by any stretch of the
imagination he the whole way to the
point where we're all arguing about food
finally and s's just like I'm gonna find
an ecigarette store for you Rob and
we're going to go check this out yes we
get to the ecigarette store Rob beines
in there and like I don't you were like
vaping in there trying out stuff you
were like lost 20 minutes I was not in
there for 20 minutes we were in the park
lot you we were like in the parking lot
for like 20 minutes he finally comes out
he's like
oh you don't mind if a vape in the car
do you yeah he says that he's already
Vaped like two or three he's
like you guys don't mind if I do this
right Dark Souls it's like Rob just
popped his humanity and he came alive
again like it was dark but but in
hindsight in hindsight is I'm just
imagining like a gas tank and mosque
like oh dude it was it was intense man
like at that point I was like whatever
gives me a nicotine fix I don't care
what it is I'll take it but um but but
in hindsight like I felt terrible on the
way home I was like man I just like
totally like was a buzz kill the weekend
he did aoll I I will give him credit for
that like and S and I weren't that
irritated with it we it was the first
day and we both we both even said I
think like because I was getting a
little more irritated than S was with
about it because we both flew in to get
business done and I felt like I was the
only one kind of pushing the weekly pull
and even s he's like you know it is his
first con I'm like all right yeah it is
his first it's a really it's a daunting
con like yeah it got big real fast like
when that show first opened like New
York Comic-Con by the way it's been in
the same location Javit Center
originally they were like come up a
convention right like what what do you
thinking like a thousand people will
show up it's only the biggest city the
United States and it will only
accommodate like the try to quad state
area no I'm sure only a thousand people
show up I think like 30,000 people
showed up and like they had it in one
section
and they had like the same line for
buying tickets as getting back into the
show oh God for the first for the first
year and the Fire Marshall came sometime
during the day and was like your con is
shut down like no one's getting in or
out like you're that's it uh and Tiff
and I of course like snuck in and
whatever but every year after that they
were like I guess we'll just get it
bigger and bigger and what what's
hilarious about that show is um the
travel the New York travel show used to
be scheduled on the same weekend and so
they would share the space so it was
like the New York ComicCon and the New
York travel show so you had like Aunt
Agnes and Grandma going to see like the
latest hot spots in the Caribbean and
like Vampirella cosplayers they do the
same thing in Toronto with Van Expo yeah
van expo's huge I want to go to that by
the way but like oh it's it's a lot of
fun because everyone goes to that
because it's like the only Canada show
where all like the creators like we got
to go to
I missed lamir and Dan slot last year
and I kicked myself so hard that I
missed them I'm just like no so now I
want all of you to try going to these
conventions cuz conventions are tiring
anyway but being cosplay cuz you can't
eat you can't pee yeah
no that hurt I am finally going to be
cosplaying for the first time ever uh
I'm G to cosplay as the comic story
yeah I can see it you totally look like
that guy you do you you need a little
bit more crazy hair though I think I
just did need more shirts with your own
face on them I just did a Harley Quinn
in Suicide Squad cosplay and I was
wearing these heels cuz it was like drag
cosplay and uh I took the heels off at
the end of the day and my feet had
literally been bleeding for I don't know
how long but I was like my performance
was great on the stage and I don't care
I don't care what your feet look like f
I'm going to end this podcast here with
the story of so I was in the military
you ever do like a 30 mile ruck march
where you got like 90 pound in your back
and you're just walking in Boots and
then when you take your shock off your
whole bottom your foot goes with it
there I
win but have you ever worn heels oh you
you got me beat I kind got to give this
one to F right here I'm sorry yeah I'll
give that one to him like I've seen some
of the heels that people I don't
understand I don't understand I'll just
leave it to that I go 30 miles in Boots
F wins because he has heels I hate you
all we should end
now all right guys with that being said
um what does everybody have going I
guess we all have Daredevil going on
this week yeah I got coming out tomorrow
Daredevil coming out Thursday Dar oh
Deadpool Thursday then it's Daredevil
Daredevil
dared we all agree that costume for
Deadpool looks awesome yes oh yeah we
talked about Deadpool now you can put it
in the tags Deadpool
anyway you're welcome so yeah um I I I'm
doing Superman Earth One for back
related here's the funny thing me and
our mean rushed to get uh Daredevil Born
Again out because I was certain you
would have done that book on back issues
I was 100% I gotta beat s to this we got
to do it today yeah no you know what's
funny with back issues it doesn't even
matter like we did Civil War like
episode four when no one watched us it's
one it's like the second most watched
episode and people are like I just
watched Civil War like they're finally
catching up like the names are it's just
so ingrained in like the search the
search history now like we can just do
it whenever as long as it gets done when
yeah that's how I with my Civil War and
for the record I do do I do do the the
tent pole programming where like oh
Daredevil's coming out I can find
stories about Daredevil I enjoy and I do
do that but at the same time the same
exact thing as s like it doesn't seem to
matter the other thing yeah we did
Guardians of the Galaxy volume one space
aveng Avengers like the same week
Guardians of the Galaxy came out made
absolutely no difference we'll all need
to coordinate and talk about what Ultron
stories we're going to do as it gets
closer to Ultron because I I can bet you
that the story me and R mean is doing is
like you guys wouldn't even think of
this story is it the Daredevil versus
ult
guys go another to Mr Sunday movies it's
like 1 am foram he's probably trying
sleep you gotta watch over those drop
bears and everything I
understand they're not real right in the
morning no that's they're not real well
we
think the Australia the Sydney Council
we we always keep F past his bedtime
anyway but I I don't understand I don't
understand how like I couldn't live in
Australia because like like my my
thought like here's my my depiction like
here's my view of Australia did you guys
ever see like after Earth with Will
Smith they went back to Earth they went
back to Earth and uh and he told his son
he was like he's like everything on this
planet has evolved to kill people that's
Australia like everything in Australia
has evolved to kill humans and so yeah
that's fair that's fair plus like the
inflation there is terrible because
don't you guys pay more for everything
in Australia for some ridiculous reason
yeah pretty pretty much yeah and the
Dollar's like well the Dollar's not that
strong to the US and all that but it's
fine we have
great bread no I don't
know and and you guys just got Netflix
just recently just in time for D we got
the worst version of Netflix though like
it's even your adorable indigenous
animals have chlamydia oh yeah abely
Chia always sounds like a fancy name to
me it's not no it's well no I mean
nobio media F I mean I I swore off I
swore off ever going to Australia when I
was watching a documentary on the
Discovery Channel with I think Steve
Irwin before he died and he was like
today we're going to go look for like
spiders in Australia and he was like the
one we're looking for is like the mother
of all spiders when it's legs are spread
out it's the size of a dinner plate and
I was like you know what I'm never going
to
Australia reason guys want know about
the weirdest place doing research for
one of our list videos about uh scariest
places there's an island of snakes every
5T there's another snake a venomous
snake I've been to Australia Twice first
time I went there was for a swimming
contest with my
school my te we were on the beach my
teachers stood on something still to
this day we don't know what but they had
to be rushed to the
hospital Proby maybe I don't know but
everything tries killing you in
Australia yeah I mean even even the
people with goat
heads I mean you guys isn't like
Australia like like has like the largest
percentage of great white sharks like
swimming
around something like that yeah but like
apparently you're likely to be like
trampled to death by a cow than
like basically Mr Sunday movies could
die at any point any and the worst part
is if you say to an Australian person oh
aren't there sharks in your Beach like
at least when you're at the beach
they'll say no it's fine we've got Nets
up that's not actually true that's just
what we tell people there are no Nets oh
my God it didn't see it didn't make a
difference for me either way because I
was thinking if Nets worked you just
wear the tights when you were swimming
and it'll be
fine all right guys I I think I think at
this point now we're just breaking down
to what's gonna kill in Australia so I
think the Pod this is the faou effect I
talked about that during Scott's podcast
I I I talked to him about that he was
like he was I talked to him I was
telling him about F and I was like I
don't know what it is but every time fa
is on the podcast like somewhere along
the line the discussion moves from like
our topics to like total pandemonium
about everything but if you if you watch
I watch back because I'm paranoid about
that it's never me that starts
it no no but the difference is we will
start tangents but we'll end them but
like we'll be like let's talk about
haggus for two seconds and you're like
haggus all right
so no the chat does that and it chat and
then you guys mention the chat because I
never look at it oh I look at it all the
time the chat goes crazy it's hilarious
well according but right now currently
the chat's blowing up about how bad
Australia is and they would like you to
make a Australia can kill you
explained explain so let's just end this
now yes let's go ahead and end this
podcast F effect explained why do they
want everything exp just explained
it all right you know you know what we
should start doing hold on we should
start doing this I'm G to say for
everyone asking for fast effects what
you should start doing Rob is just
piecing that segment out of like oh they
want to explain well here's in the
podcast when we did it you just put it
into another video yeah hey you know if
F ever did a podcast I think F effect is
a good name for a
f you're gon have four CopyCats in the
yeah say F go lock that down now because
the last time we mentioned a potential
name it got taken like in 10
minutes internet man all right guys um
so we're we're gonna end this podcast
before we go too far are we are we
really yes we are like for the fourth
time he guys I got a great story to tell
you guys about hookers and Taiwan uh you
want me to do that now or later awesome
show discussion that's what that is I
have one too but it involves Scott lell
and I'm not allowed to tell that one
anymore oh yeah all right anyway um so
we all have D devil coming out this week
so uh yeah I guess we'll go ahead and
call it a day we all don't F doesn't f
okay F doesn't what I have Team tit and
stuff in my usual
stick okay we we will we will catch
everybody later peace bye